[Music]
on this Wednesday night a final salute
to the Fallen six Canadian Armed Forces
members who died in a helicopter crash
honored in an extraordinary ceremony
Canada's worst kovat 19 hotspot why the
virus keeps spreading in Montreal as
another province is on the road to
reopening contact tracing there's an app
for that we're breaking news a
transmission through the contact tracing
Alberta's new weapon in the war against
kovat 19 but is it effective and
celebrating a first little Archie's big
milestone
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with a solemn ceremony to honor
the six members of the Canadian Forces
who died in a helicopter crash off the
coast of Greece only one body has been
found and so there was only one casket
carried off the aircraft at this
repatriation ceremony in Trenton Ontario
that of 23-year old sub leftenant
Abigail Cobra the others were honored in
a simple and moving act just their hats
carried on black pillows to a lineup of
waiting hearses where family and friends
paid their respects reminders of the
pandemic on the faces of everyone there
including the prime minister for air
crew and two sailors died when their
cyclone helicopter crashed while on a
NATO training mission one week ago Ross
Lord reports on how the Dead were
honored when most of their remains are
lost at sea after what historians call
the worst helicopter crash in Canadian
military history comes out repatriation
ceremony unlike any other
the body of one crash victim sub
left-handed Abigail Cobra has been
brought back from the Mediterranean Sea
to be returned to her family but
military leaders along with the Prime
Minister had to honor the other five
victims differently with their remains
still at sea pillows with the members
service headdress on top are carried
from a military plane to waiting hearses
those members are captain Brendan Ian
McDonald a pilot from New Glasgow Nova
Scotia who has two siblings in the Armed
Forces captain Kevin Hagen also a pilot
from the Nemo British Columbia
remembered for his positivity and his
passion for flying an adventure captain
Maxime Metamora an air combat systems
officer from 12 Revere Quebec who along
with three other victims graduated from
the Royal Military College of Canada sub
leftenant Matthew Pike a naval warfare
officer from Truro Nova Scotia who was
engaged to be married and master
corporal Matthew Cousins an airborne
electronic sensor operator from Guelph
Ontario who served in the Army Reserves
for several years before joining the Air
Force as their families grieve the
victims presence is felt far beyond
Canadian Forces Base Trenton including
in Nova Scotia where the cyclone
helicopter and its ship HMCS Fredericton
are based there's gonna be five families
up there that are not going to receive
the remains of their of their lost loved
one and and that's that is that's gut
ripping it really is Jerry white is a
family friend of sub leftenant Cobra he
and other veterans spoke to her father
before the ceremony I said I do my best
work at 4 o'clock in the morning and he
texted me back immediately he said I'm
glad to hear that because that's when
everything is quiet and the tears flow
best families also met privately with
the prime minister after the ceremony a
motorcade traveled down the highway of
heroes to Toronto where the coroner's
office will conduct an autopsy on
Abigail Cobras remains even in times of
physical distancing some scenes of
tribute remain the same
Ross Lord Global News Halifax
a Nova Scotia intersection was shut down
today as part of the investigation into
last month's mass shooting there our CMP
officers spent several hours using a
drone to capture aerial images of the
spot where constable Heidi Stevenson
died she was one of 22 people killed
during the nearly 14 hours shooting
rampage in Nova Scotia it ended when an
officer fatally shot the 51 year old
gunman at a gas station now to what
continues to be the big story of the day
and the year the pandemic Quebec has
been hardest hit in Canada there are now
more than 34,000 confirmed cases in that
province that represents more than half
the confirmed cases in the whole country
Quebec has also had the most deaths more
than 2,500 lives lost and roughly half
the people who have become infected in
Quebec are in Montreal it's also in
Montreal where more than 1500 people
have died so what is it about that city
and the response that's led to this Mike
Armstrong is looking into that tonight
this is the hottest spot for kovat 19 in
Canada's hardest hit city the rate of
infection in the borough of Montreal
north is about 50% higher than the next
two closest hot spots is a densely
populated multi-ethnic area and
community groups want to know if those
are factors they're calling on the
province to release data that breaks
down who's been infected we call it
social determinants of health factors
such as race income level eventually
even the family status now there are no
hospitals in the area so they've set up
a temporary testing facility what there
are a lot of our health care workers
nurses auxiliary nurses and orderlies
one theory is that those occupations are
a factor probably we have health care
workers and other essential workers that
have contract the virus and that I've
brought the virus in their family now a
Donna usual monopoly did since the
beginning the province is called
Montreal the big challenge things are
basically under control everywhere else
businesses have started reopening in
other regions daycares and elementary
schools reopened next Monday in the
Montreal region everything will be
two weeks for businesses one week for
schools although that could move even
further but despite still struggling to
flatten the curve Quebec is pushing
ahead as the only province or state in
North America to bring kids back to the
classroom
well one mistake Quebec is admitting it
made is in long-term care facilities in
April when other provinces were banning
staff from working in multiple seniors
homes Quebec health officials allowed it
to continue they will wear masks and so
they will not contaminate the province
now says it wants staff to stay in one
facility and not move around we're
implementing this everywhere and we want
the organization's to follow this
principle very strictly no testing is
still a massive issue the province has
been doing about 7,000 tests a day it's
pledging to get that up to 14,000 by
Friday Mike Armstrong Global News
Montreal more testing is key and by this
time tomorrow Canada will likely have
carried out its one millionth test for
kovat 19 more than nine hundred and
seventy thousand people have been tested
so far the chief public health officer
of Canada dr. Teresa Tam says she would
like 60 thousand tests done every day
right now were at less than half that
about 25 thousand tests a day that's why
we don't have a full understanding of
how many people have been infected what
we do know is the majority of tests do
come back negative across Canada about
63,000 people have now tested positive
for kovat 19 more than 4300 people have
died almost all the new infections and
new deaths are in Ontario and Quebec
most other provinces and territories are
reporting single digit increases now or
no new cases at all Saskatchewan had 25
new cases today there were 70 in Alberta
and 23 positive cases reported in
British Columbia today and in DC cases
of kovat 19 have been on a downward
trend for a while now today premier John
Horgan announced plans to start lifting
some restrictions global v sees Richards
s Minh is in Victoria Richard what is
their restart strategy in BC
dawna the big part of the restart
strategy as a term being dubbed as
doubling your bubble so people will be
able to expand their social circles by
the May long weekend but not too much
and every individual will be different
they need to assess whether they can
expose their loved ones potentially to
getting kovat 19:00 there also will be a
concerted effort to start opening up
more businesses including a target to
have restaurants open by the middle of
May it's a slow approach Premier John
Horgan says things like concerts and big
events will not happen in British
Columbia until there is a vaccine and
the priority will be around insuring
people have these expanded social
circles as we start to relax some of the
social restrictions small social
gatherings with physical distancing will
be allowed the choices you make about
span expanding your social circle will
depend on your age your occupation and
the health of the people that you live
with a big part to all of this as well
Donna is a slow gradual reopening of the
schools K to 12 will be reopening but
only on a voluntary basis and there will
be a number of new measures in place for
schools across British Columbia
including health checks that will be
conducted every day people will not have
to get their temperature taken but they
will be asked every day if they're
feeling okay there could potentially be
phased classes and also there will be
enhanced cleaning in classrooms all
right Richard Sussman in Victoria thank
you
well three key things must be in place
to safely reopen the economy enough
testing to find positive cases contact
tracing to identify anyone they came in
contact with and a place for those
people to isolate test
trace isolate is the mantra and
governments everywhere are figuring out
how best to do it because even when the
curve is flattened the virus is still
out there
smartphone apps are one way to contact
trace Alberta is using one but as
Heather Europe's West explains it's far
from perfect the people in this room are
doing some of the most important
in the fight against kovat 19 they are
contact tracers and their job is to find
people who may have been exposed sort of
breaking chains and transmission through
the contact tracing and also identifying
as I said potential sources that there
might be a clustering that we need to
identify without proper contact tracing
a small outbreak can quickly get out of
hand but the work is tedious and
imperfect relying on people to remember
everywhere they went and everyone they
saw going back two weeks or more if you
ask them what they did three to one day
ago four days ago
five days ago it takes a while for that
recalling it's why provinces are looking
at supplementing their contact tracing
work with new technology Alberta was the
first to launch its own smartphone app a
be traced together uses Bluetooth to
build a record of other app enabled
phones that have been nearby within two
meters for at least fifteen minutes
those records are kept on the phone for
twenty-one days if a user tests positive
for covert 19 they can consent to upload
those records to assist Public Health
contact tracers who can then call anyone
who may have been exposed but in order
for the app to work on iPhones users
must make sure the app is open and the
phone is unlocked every time they go out
and while more than 100,000 of buttons
have downloaded the app more than 2
million need to use it in order for it
to work the University of Oxford study
details it pretty well we need 50 to 60%
adoption rate in order for these apps to
be effective
Morgan chance team has developed a
different kind of app one that uses GPS
whether to adopt an app and which one is
a decision each province and territory
will have to make but there's a growing
call for national strategy as well
because if people keep use all different
kind of tools then they will be more
difficult and some contacts of course
may go in between provinces I think
that's a important area of discussion
with little time to waste as Canada
works towards a new normal under the
still present threat of copán 19 Heather
at your ex west global news Calgary
Alberta Zenergy regulator has suspended
more than a dozen environmental rules at
various oil sands projects after four
major oil companies asked for relief
during the Cova 19 pandemic
the decision affects the operations of
Imperial Oil Suncor Syncrude and
Canadian Natural Resources Limited they
no longer need to do things such as test
ground and surface water look for
leaking gases measure toxic pollution
from stacks or monitor wildlife and
birds at tailings ponds the Alberta
Energy Regulator says the suspensions
are likely to remain in place as long as
there are kovat 19 related orders under
the Public Health Act Canada's oil and
gas sector is made repeated pleas for
aid from the federal government because
of Kovach 19 and the huge drop in oil
prices now two of Canada's opposition
leaders the Green Party's Elizabeth May
and Bloc Quebecois leader Yves Francois
blast-jet
are weighing in with some strong
opinions my heart bleeds for people who
believe the sector is going to come back
because it's not oil is dead and it's
for people in the sector it's very
important that there be just transition
funds I do agree with mrs. me about the
fact that if oil industry as a whole
might not be so dead I think tar sands
are condemned and putting any more money
in that business is a very bad idea
weeks ago Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
promised sector-specific support for the
oil and gas industry beyond the 1.7
billion dollars the government has
allocated to clean up abandoned well
sites the US president announces changes
coming up the White House coronavirus
Task Force stays in place but shifts its
focus bus
an action by New York City subway system
ground to a halt
for the first time in its 115 year
history the entire New York subway
system was deliberately shut down
overnight workers cleaned and
disinfected the cars to reduce the risk
of spreading Kovach 19 a shutdown
between 1:00 and 5:00 a.m. is going to
be a nightly occurrence subway use in
New York is down 90% but about 11,000
people still rely on the trains during
those overnight hours the governor of
New York says Cove aide 19 is on the
retreat in his state and he plans to
take a cautious approach to reopening
the economy but President Donald Trump
is pushing hard to get the whole country
back to business acknowledging that
means people will still be at risk of
getting sick and dying and as Jackson
prosecco reports he's making some
changes to his coronavirus task force
this is worse than Pearl Harbor this is
worse than the World Trade Center in the
fight against kovat 19 the Trump
administration has made a stark choice
shifting its focus to reopening of
businesses a move the president admits
will all but certainly lead to more
deaths we have to be worried as weak we
can't keep our country closed down for
years on Tuesday Trump suggested
scrapping the White House coronavirus
task force with its team of medical
experts now he's going to retool it to
focus on the economy the panel's
previous guidelines for a stage
reopening were all but ignored by state
after state the concern is going forward
we would miss you even more disfunction
add to that a new whistleblower
complaint from a government doctor who
says he tried to raise alarms about the
pandemic response and was ignored it
paints a damning picture of the US
response the administration was very
intent on providing good news and in
sugarcoating how devastating this virus
going to was going to be dr. Rick bright
claims he warned about shortages of
supplies like masks in January and he
pushed back against the use of unproven
treatments touted by the president that
ultimately cost him his job I was
pressured to let politics and cronyism
drive decision the details are very
concerning that it wasn't just a
difference of opinion there was this
regard seemingly of science the science
suggests the outbreak is far from under
control
with cases growing so fast in dozens of
states that they're making up for the
declines seen in hard-hit New York the
result is that the u.s. is still
recording thousands of deaths every day
Jackson prosto Global News Washington
well anyway now what do you want to do
[Music]
he's done with that chapter ahead
celebrating a royal first
a picture is emerging of the economic
damage in the European Union the EU is
forecasting a deep and uneven recession
it says the 27 nation economy has
entered the deepest economic recession
in its history it's forecast to contract
by a record 7.5 percent this year and
though growth of about 6 percent is
predicted in 2021 uncertainty is
exceptionally high the euro is expected
to drop nearly 8 percent this year the
worst hit countries are expected to be
Greece Spain and Italy and the European
Commission warns without some form of
common rescue plan distortions in how
each country copes could threaten the
stability of Europe Germany's top soccer
league has been given the green light to
restart this month the Bundesliga will
be Europe's first major Football League
to return to the pitch during the
pandemic there are strict rules in place
though players will be regularly tested
for kovat 19:00 they won't all use one
locker room and all games will take
place in empty stadiums the teams are
expected to confirm the start date
tomorrow and because we all need a break
from the grim news here's the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex with a video of their
son Archie to mark his first birthday
defeat he's dragged his mom Megan Markel
is reading one of his favorite books the
video was posted on Instagram as part of
us Save the Children fundraising
campaign for children and families
struggling because of the impact of
Coppa 19 and it was shot by Harry you
can hear him cheering at the end
[Applause]
happy first birthday arty thank you from
the street next a special salute to nine
neighbors
and now familiar ritual has become part
of our new reality the pot banging
clanging every night at 7:00 p.m. it's
the equivalent of a standing ovation for
essential workers especially those who
work in hospitals and care homes one
Ottawa Street is especially loud because
it's home to nine doctors and nurses and
the whole street is cheering them on
well we'll use videographer Mike Haslett
when to listen we got a call from David
Chow who said it would be really cool to
cheer his wife on when she came home at
shift change
she's an ICU nurse so we all thought
that was a great idea and we started
coming out at 7:00 to cheer on Kathy it
was a number of neighbors that came out
at 8 o'clock when she got home and they
clapped just for her and you could see
the look on her face and you can see the
smile that came out and you could see
how it's almost like the some of the
stress had just sort of melted away we
have four doctors and we have five
nurses just in a very short stretch of
street that that that were on and I
think it's touched a lot of people we
started it once a week and then Dave
came up and said they're doing it in the
UK every day at 7 o'clock at shift
change let's do it then we come out in
the rain we come out in the snow and we
come out in the Sun as a nurse who works
in the community that makes me feel
really loved and supported to see my
neighbors every night at 7 caught me off
guard
the first time a neighbor thanked me and
I said for what and they said for
helping patients it really is
inspirational and motivational and helps
us go in everyday what we're doing every
day out on the front lines is tough but
I think what everybody's doing at home
is tough - everybody's given up a lot to
stay at home we're all in this together
I think that's that's an important theme
I think that's really important for
everyone to know is that you know we're
facing this pandemic and and we're
facing it together
the look on the face and you know how
grateful they were that that people were
thinking of them it really touches your
heart sure does and that is global
national for this Wednesday I'm Donna
Friesen thanks for watching take care of
yourselves bye bye
[Music]